- [Voiceover] So in the last video,
we talked about the year 1864
in the American Civil War,
and now we're getting down
to the very end of the war.
In 1864, William Tecumseh Sherman had his
sort of famous march to the sea,
where he captured Atlanta and
then carried on a total war
through the state of Georgia to Savannah,
and from Savannah he turns north
and starts heading to the forces of Grant,
so he can back him up in a
final victory against Lee,
who has encamped in Richmond.
Meanwhile, Abraham Lincoln
wins the election of 1864,
and is ready to bring this war to a close.
So let's move on to 1865.
A lot happens very quickly in 1865,
starting with, in January,
Congress passed the 13th Amendment.
The 13th Amendment outlawed
slavery for all time.
It's clear that when the
south is brought back in
to the United States, it is
going to be brought back in
without slavery, there
is no option for slavery
in the United States going forward.
Now Grant, after his incredible
victory in Tennessee,
in Vicksburg, has been going
after Lee's army in Virginia.
Now Lee has holed up in
Richmond and eventually,
he realizes his forces
can't stay there anymore,
they can't hold the city, so
in the beginning of April,
they evacuate Richmond and on April 3rd,
the United States forces occupy Richmond.
Abraham Lincoln himself actually goes down
to visit Richmond, which
he'd never been to before,
and he even goes to the
government building in Richmond
where Confederate President
Jefferson Davis had governed,
and goes into his office.
He's there less than 48 hours
after Davis himself had left.
And then events, after that,
events take place very quickly.
So Lee falls back from
Richmond to Petersburg,
and Grant is kind of
marking him the whole time,
and they retreat across
Virginia to the west,
Lee is probably heading for Lynchburg,
and Grant manages to catch
up with him at Appomattox.
At first, Lee thinks that he's actually
going to fight at Appomattox,
and then he realizes he just does not
have the men necessary, so
he invites Grant to come
and have a parlay for
surrender, and they meet,
this is actually a picture
of Lee outside the house
in Appomattox courthouse, Virginia,
where he surrendered the Army of
Northern Virginia to Grant.
Now that is not the actual
end of the Civil War,
but it's kind of the end
for all intents and purposes
because Lee is the General-in-Chief
of the Confederate Armies.
Grant is likewise for the United States.
And after this point, it's just gonna be
kind of a matter of
time until all the rest
of the Confederate armies surrender.
So there's great celebration
in Washington, D.C.,
everyone is very happy, finally
this four year long war,
where 620,000 Americans
have died, is over,
and Abraham Lincoln
goes and gives a speech,
talking about what Reconstruction
is going to be like.
And in this speech, he lays
out that African Americans,
after the Civil War, are
going to have citizenship,
at least some of them,
and the right to vote,
which is in keeping with
everything that he's really said
since the Emancipation Proclamation.
But what he does not
know, is that this man,
John Wilkes Booth, is
in the crowd that day,
listening to him, and
when he hears Lincoln say
that African Americans are
gonna have citizenship,
they're gonna have the right to vote,
he vows to kill Lincoln.
John Wilkes Booth is really
interesting character,
we only know so much about him.
He himself was a famous actor, in fact,
Lincoln had seen him
perform a number of times,
and liked him, even invited
him to the White House,
cause he thought he was a great actor,
but Booth refused to go and see Lincoln.
And he was from a family of famous actors,
I think kind of a modern-day equivalent
might be the Sheen family.
Booth had a famous brother
who was also an actor,
and a famous father who was also an actor,
just like Martin Sheen's
sons are Emilio Estevez
and Charlie Sheen today.
So this would be like, if
Emilio Estevez or Charlie Sheen
suddenly decided to murder the President,
which would be a pretty
incredibly big deal,
just as it was then.
Booth was a Confederate sympathizer,
and almost certainly a Confederate spy
who had gone up to Canada at some time
to plot some movement on
behalf of the Confederacy.
He was an outright racist,
I think the part where
Lincoln said African Americans
would have citizenship
was what pushed him over the edge
into assassinating Lincoln.
Originally he had actually
planned to kidnap Lincoln,
and ransom him for the
end of the Civil War,
but after Lee surrenders,
Booth's plan changes.
He wants to basically
decapitate the government,
so he conspires with a
couple of other people,
and they plan that they're going to kill
all the highest people
in government at once.
So they're going to kill Lincoln,
they're going to kill General Grant,
they're going to kill William Seward,
the secretary of state,
and they're going to kill Andrew Johnson,
the Vice-President.
And Booth thinks that perhaps,
in this moment of panic that follows
the decapitation of the entire
United States government,
that perhaps something positive
for the south with happen.
Remember, they had hoped
that getting rid of Lincoln
in the election of 1864
might result in putting
a government more favorable to the south
in office to the north,
which didn't happen,
so perhaps Booth wants to
do the same thing this time.
So Booth reads in the
newspaper that Abraham Lincoln
is going to be attending
a play at Ford's Theater
that evening.
And Booth is a regular at Ford's Theater,
in fact, he even has his
mail delivered there,
so it's kind of his home away from home.
And when Booth goes to the theater
with the intent to kill Lincoln,
he pretty much just goes
up to Lincoln's box,
and everyone knows who he is,
and they say hi John,
and he just walks on by,
walks right into Lincoln's box,
shuts the door behind him,
and shoots Lincoln through
the back of the head.
At that point, he jumped on
the stage from the booth,
which is maybe 14 feet above the stage.
If you've never been to Ford's Theater
and you have an opportunity,
I highly recommend you go,
it's a really interesting
museum and historical place,
and in the process, he
actually breaks his ankle,
so in his running away he's dealing with
this broken ankle and
eventually he is captured,
and refuses to be taken
alive, so he is killed.
And later the rest of the
conspirators are hanged
for their participation in this plot.
There's some confusion
over what Booth said
when he jumped out of the box.
A lot of people say that he
yelled sic semper tyrannis,
which means, thus always to tyrants,
and is also the motto of
the state of Virginia.
Other people heard him say
things like I've done it,
or revenge for the south,
but sic semper tyrannis
is kind of the famous phrase
that has come out of this.
So Booth is calling Lincoln a tyrant,
and tyrants are eventually
always assassinated.
The rest of the assassination plot
from that evening mostly failed.
One of the conspirators, Lewis Powell,
did manage to get in to
William Seward's house
and stab him, he did not
succeed in killing him,
but he did wound Seward very badly.
The rest of the assassination plots
did not come to fruition whatsoever.
One thing you'll notice
is that only a few parts
of the Confederate Army
have actually surrendered
at the time of Lincoln's assassination.
So the war is, in some
cases, still ongoing,
particularly in North Carolina,
in Raleigh and Durham,
where Sherman's forces have come up
through South Carolina and North Carolina
to meet the forces of
Confederate General Joe Johnston.
And it's on April the
26th that Joe Johnston
surrenders to William Tecumseh Sherman.
From that point forward, there
are a few dribs and drabs
of other armies that
are still surrendering.
Interesting fact, the last
Confederate unit to surrender
actually surrendered in November of 1865,
in Liverpool, England,
this was a Confederate ship
that had been sailing around,
and when they finally came into port,
they officially surrendered.
Now after Lincoln's assassination,
which was an incredible
shock to the United States,
remember that no President had ever
been assassinated before,
the power is then transferred
to Andrew Johnson,
Lincoln's Vice-President.
And Johnson's Presidency
is going to end up
being very problematic
for a number of reasons,
the most important of which being that
he's very sympathetic to the south.
With Johnson in power as President,
he's going to have a
considerable amount of conflict
with the American Congress,
which is dominated
by radical Republicans who
think that Lincoln himself
was not nearly punitive
enough toward the south.
There's going to be just an
incredible battle of wills
between Congress and
Johnson that's going to end
with Johnson being the
first American President
to be impeached.
And so thus endeth the Civil
War of the United States,
with the north victorious.
The southern states come
back into the Union.
The rebellion in the south is defeated,
slavery has ended, and the
era of states rights is over.
In the next video I'd like to talk,
just for a few moments,
about the big takeaways
about the American Civil War.
What is is that makes it so important?
And what were the lasting effects?
I'll get to that in the next video.